benjamin cuche bonjour et merci d'être
en direct avec nous ce matin sur rtl
france renault mise en examen conteste
avoir commis la moindre infraction
quel est votre avis là-dessus que juge
d'instruction met en examen c'est une
chose que renault compte est sans doute
une autre à l'instruction va permettre
de dévoiler ou paille en chemin vers la
vérité et c'est comme une enchère calcé
longue ça fait comme les années que ça
très bon et on peut se demander pourquoi
la mise en examen intervient que
maintenant je dire aux états unis la
justice était beaucoup plus rapide en
allemagne la justice était beaucoup plus
rapide
là ça tombe six ans après c'est
quasiment ridicule quoi justement
comment est-ce que renault peut
aujourd'hui se défend de ces accusations
ces accusations oserons nous de prouver
que nous avons connues volkswagen a
également gt est également mise en cause
dans cette affaire on sait qu'il a déjà
plaidé coupable coupable de fraude en
2017 30 milliards d'euros de dommages et
intérêts ont été versés ce que cette
affaire peut aujourd'hui porter un grand
coup d'arrêt au constructeur allemand
non non parce que c'est le constructeur
allemand c'est 600 mille six cent mille
employés dans le monde
c'est 11 millions de véhicules produits
par an et c'est mon entreprise suffisait
qu'elle suffisamment les reins solides
et la réalité c'est que c'est la justice
américaine qui a racketté une entreprise
européenne comme elle sait si bien faire
depuis des années on a vu avec la france
on avec la générale et la bnp la réac
alstom on l'a enlevé
guardian c'est juste c'est juste un
racket de le du gouvernement américain
sur le chemin d'une entreprise
industrielle européenne et la renault on
se demande pourquoi les la mise en
examen intervient sitter et les risques
les risques financiers de renault sont
nettement moindres que ceux de
volkswagen ça peut pas excéder 20
millions d'euros d'amande et les
dommages intérêts pour les clients
citant taki et renault a été condamnée
ce qui n'est pas du tout acquis ne
serait pas ne serait pas d'une telle
ampleur
ça va peut-être de l'ampleur pour une
bonne raison ah bon c'est que le ses
clés des dommages intérêts en france non
plafonné et qu'il faut prouver le
préjudice qu on a subi or le préjudice
qu on assouplit subi d'acheter une
voiture diesel consomme à peine un
millier de plus au sens il est pas
fondamentalement de gravissime aux
points condamné renault à des milliards
de dommages intérêts doit-on s'attendre
à un effet domino est ce que d'autres
constructeurs automobiles pourraient
être mises en examen dans cette affaire
pour l'instant pour l'instant s'il ya
pas d'instructions constructeurs en
particulier il ya pas de raison c'est
que c'est toujours à la justice de paix
que la personne à l'accusateur de
prouver que la personne est coupable
c'est pas et pas à l'accusé de prouver
son innocence
et heureusement d'ailleurs et là il faut
que les gens qui accuse renault d'avoir
des gens progrès pas dernière question
est ce que cette affaire risque
d'impacter le secteur automobile selon
vous le secteur du diesel
certainement mais comme il est pourri
qu'on le diesel est quand même assez
moribonde ce qu'on est descendu à moins
en moins de 25 % des immatriculations
diaz l eau en 2021 depuis le début et
qu'on est passé aux pratiques d'autres
types de carburants est ce que c'est
vraiment grave non le disent elle fait
partie du passé pour bien des cas il va
être interdite dans trois ans je trouve
que c'est vraiment une quête un peu et
il ya peut-être d'autres choses et
marrante avec la justice et moi
dirigeante à s'inquiéter du tas de
carlos ghosn le cadre renault rno c'est
des emplois car olten c'est quelqu'un
qui a été condamné encore la semaine
dernière auront payé par la justice
française c'est quand même moins
diligente à venir s'enquérir de la
situation de carlos ghosn de celle de
renault sas est plus préoccupant par
contre merci beaucoup en tout cas
benjamin accuse d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste automobile est l'auteur de
l' ouvrage le livre noir de renault aux
éditions first endémique triste